die schweiz überwältigende bergpanoramen
atemberaubende natur und ein
musikalisches nationalsymbol dass born
dem rund dreieinhalb meter langen
instrument zu ihren treffen sich jedes
jahr tausende alphorn fans in im kanton
wallis
ich komme aus belgien im flämischen teil
ich komme aus manchester in
großbritannien rund 4000 alphornbläser
sind in der schweiz aktiv hier in nada
auf dem größten alphorn festival des
landes treffen sich 150 musiker aus der
ganzen welt die meisten von ihnen sind
über 50
doch es gibt auch junge
instrumentalisten die lust auf das
iphone haben was ich vielleicht jetzt
ein bisschen tendenziell an bahn ist
dass verschiedene jüngere auch versuchen
ein bisschen aus der folklore heraus zu
kommen sondern eher daneben müssen in
jazzige oder dann auch in chromatische
tonlagen zu spielen sofern das möglich
ist
[Musik]
je nach horn können zwölf bis sechzehn
töne erzeugt werden genug um auch
zeitgenössische stücke zu spielen
die internationale gruppe die sisters
hat sich darauf spezialisiert
[Musik]
man kann natürlich nicht alles spielen
aber unseren stil können wir durch
auswählen
es ist erzählte man eine trompete ohne
ventile
wir haben begrenzte möglichkeiten eine
zeit lang galt folklore als langweilig
aber jetzt scheint es als gebe es ein
comeback
und ich glaube das alphorn spielen jetzt
wieder richtig cool ist es ist wirklich
im trend ursprünglich war das alphorn
quasi das handy der hirten und das nicht
nur in europa auch in asien wurde es von
den meisten füttern als
kommunikationsmittel genutzt
im verlauf der fast 500 jährigen
geschichte verstummte das alphorn in der
schweiz immer mehr nada gilt heutzutage
als hauptstadt des instruments hier
spielt es fast jeder sowie patricia
amorim
meine mutter ist auch alpinisten
sie spielt mit mir in einer gruppe ich
glaube ich habe damit angefangen weil
sie es gespielt hat und ich dachte es
ist ein cooles instrument und jetzt bin
ich hier
viele alphornbläser brauchen auch viele
alphörner
in der schweiz gibt es rund 40 der
spezialisierten instrumentenbauer
einer von ihnen ist france soir muricy
zwei wochen ist er mit einem instrument
beschäftigt fünf bis acht jahre muss das
holz der schweizer rot anne trocknen ehe
er es verarbeiten kann er wählen einen
baum aus der auf nährstoffarmen boden
wächst aufseher steinigem untergrund
wächst er sehr langsam und nicht so hoch
die leitungsbahnen im baum sind sehr eng
wodurch das wachstum verlangsamt wird
solches holz suchen wir nennen es
klangholz es ist das gleiche holz aus
dem man gegen gitarren und ähnliche
musik instrumente baut mit stolz halten
die männer aus zadar und umgebung auch
andere bräuche aufrecht wie das
sogenannte geistlich lockern und das bei
dem riesigen kuhglocken geläutet werden
der höhepunkt ist aber das gesamte spiel
der 150 alphornbläser und das wird ganz
sicher auch nächstes jahr so sein wenn
das festival im südschweizer kanton
wallis in die neunzehnte runde geht
[Musik]